scp-2406 also known as the Colossus is a
93 meter tall 210 ton mechanical
automaton discovered in the aralcomm
desert in 1985 made primarily of a
bronze-like alloy it is hypothesized to
have been operated by six Pilots powered
by a nuclear reactor and shows extensive
signs of combat related damage within
scp-2406 were six human skeletons from
around 1 200 to 1000 BCE a tired and
unconventional armor and a complex
system of tubes and valves to maintain
hydration and ventilation a large tank
found within the right arm contained
residues of flammable and reactive
substances the foundation keeps scp-2406
within provisional site-31 guarded to
prevent unauthorized access despite its
damaged State the possibility of
scp-2406 being repairable exists
although it currently Remains the only
one of its kind known to the foundation